so we have a little clip to show you um
remember Sharna Sharna was none she
wasn't a pro this season but Sharna of
Dancing with the Stars might become the
Bachelorette in Australia so she's got a
little message for you how to help a
girl out am I supposed to do the
Bachelorette or not I'm stressed should
Sharna do it I I'm so like I mean if the
opportunity comes to you that doesn't
come to everybody I think even even I
would say yeah I feel like you should do
it and Shana you'll be great you can
keep those get those boys in check
that's what you got you have to be able
to do but a lot of people ask me like
yep would you do it again or like I'm
thinking about like just going for it
and there has been success in the
franchise and I think if that's the way
you're supposed to find your person
you'll find it but what so why not
and so yeah go for it Shana you guys
it's the finals is this surreal is it
exciting how do you feel
all the above it is really exciting I
think at this point we just have to
enjoy it but it's kind of bittersweet I
think like my body hurts everywhere so
bad his body hurts really bad like words
tired but it's gonna be sad when it it's
this is it so we got to bring the best
we got to make the most of it yeah you
got to take this home I mean when you
look back at how far you have come
did you have any idea you'd be here in
the finals what did you think in the
very beginning about how this could all
go
honestly I said this all last week I
still can't believe it I wake up I'm
like oh my god all the hard work has
paid off and now it's like just enjoy it
I mean I didn't you never know what to
expect with with the fans voting you
never know what happens but Bachelor
nation's been amazing we've got some new
fans that are supporting us and it's the
most incredible feeling to be here
my goal was to make it here there was a
lot of good competition this season and
a lot of shocking eliminations and so
there was moments where I was like oh if
I'm gonna make it here but I did and I
know that I've put in the work and
really I've progressed a lot too and
that's been really cool to look back at
where I started to where I am now now
that I'm here I feel like you had that
confidence like you said you put it in
out there you you almost vision boarded
it you were like I want to do this this
experience has really tested my
confidence and it helped it in a lot of
ways but also like put it to the test of
like okay when when things are don't go
great or it is a challenging week for me
like can you still keep that going on
and I really have tried to but I don't
know I've always envisioned this but
getting here is just the best feeling
and I just want to really just take it
all in and enjoy it and see it through
so you guys have had this incredible
support like you said the bachelor
nation fans have been rabid but you have
had some moments with the judges and in
the finale the judges scores are very
much taken into account along with the
fan votes how are you feeling heading
into that I'm really happy with the
dances we have this week I feel like
this Showcase Hannah in the best way and
she really rises to the occasion
you know she's dancing the most if I do
say so myself she yes she is a really
very intricate and fun routine for the
Freestyle and and we're redoing our
Viennese Waltz that we did to love her
and that was one of our most like
cherished dances it felt so good to go
out there and it just felt natural I
don't really worry about the judges in
this in this case because they're trying
to help and they're going to be
supportive and I think they're gonna see
how much I've grown in the Freestyle
like what I've learned and taken from
their critiques and I really feel like
we put it into our dances so I'm not I'm
not worried about that and I just want
everyone the judges the fans the
audience to enjoy the performances and
see that okay this is a dance that just
symbolizes and it's all things
Hina's journey and I think that'll
that'll be it he did a really great job
ask you this last week will you be
shirtless again on Monday night no no
open bagel I was stressed eating this
morning and no open shirt
[Music]
now last time you did lover you got a
little shout out from Taylor Swift on
Instagram I added do you have her number
of you texted her Taylor can you get
some votes for me Taylor yeah please
Taylor oppa girl out
no I guess we're friends on the
Instagram but not really because she
doesn't follow me but I definitely
follow her
so we'll see maybe she can help us you
can help us out Taylor help us out or
anybody just fun for us you guys are
heading in with the free style can you
tease that a little bit more what we can
expect from that is that emotional does
it go back into the the full journey of
your whole life of your your love life
what is it
I think it's empowering girl power and
it's super strong it's the Hannah beast
but in an evolved way yeah I feel like
it is all that I've learned and kind of
gained from the experiences that I've
been through is to like own the woman
that I am and to really be confident in
that and I think that's what this dance
this place Allen you've never won before
all right how bad do you want I wake up
every morning I'm like Sasha hasn't are
you guys talking about that competition
a little bit yeah I mean honestly if
anyone wins
they all deserve it but I feel like
Hannah really put in that word it would
be the most incredible feeling I can't
even picture what it is like I can't
even imagine what its gonna feel like if
we are lucky enough to win oh I can I
just want to get that on Bachelorette
you deserve it I know that's I feel like
it would be like such a full circle
thing if I could have
my happy ending here with with a trophy
in my hand that's the thing you did in
writing together you were on this big
platform and it you didn't get that
happy I think it's so are you feeling
like I want to have a moment that's a
powerful positive moment for me yeah and
I think we've I definitely want that for
the end of this and I think we're doing
everything we can to have that but
either way I mean the dance is that I'm
getting to perform really make me feel
like everything that I've been through
like has
it's how it was supposed to be and I
feel like this is just a beautiful
celebration of that through dance I have
talked about this cuz look your season
just ended a couple months ago Peter
starting you're like everyone's asking
about my love life all the time what
would you want to talk about next if
it's like I want to close that chapter
what do you want the next topic of your
discussion to be in interviews and the
next chapter for you yeah I realized
that my love life is like how I got here
so it is sometimes it is sometimes like
oh god nope I'm still single I'm still
like doing this thing but I think it's
more about like I learned so much in
this and I really want to take what I've
learned and really put it back into the
community and empower more young girls
and and maybe some of the difficulties
that I went through as a young woman
that they can have the confidence to not
have to go through that and I think it's
really more for me about getting back
and what I can do through my experiences
to help others and that's what I want to
fund one of the focuses that I want to
be on but I have a lot of great
opportunities after this so well I'll
have to stay tuned
[Music]